e e
we will get started um I just wanted to
say I'm I'm planning to try to start all
of our meetings right on time okay
because because um it it it works a lot
more smoothly if if we're all here and
we're all on time and keep to the clock
and and that sort of thing um and I'm
also planning to have us have an hour
and 15 minutes for lunch in general
because because sometimes an hour is a
little you know it's a little tight but
and unfortunately representative rung uh
has pneumonia so we're hoping to see her
next week but um she's she's on
antibiotics and stuff so she won't be
here today all right and so today we
have with us um our so we're such a good
such an important division we don't have
just one LBA assistant we have two right
because if you looked at that list of um
Personnel we have um in our division in
our uh
agencies um half more than half I guess
of the employees of of the state right
so uh so this is you know there's a lot
of a lot of agencies we have to deal
with you know they're they're on the
smaller side but um but they're all
quite important um so I'll introduce um
our our sort of senior assistant is
Melissa Rollins and uh Jack Mullen just
just joined us this year and so one of
the most important pieces of paper in
this booklet is this second page which
will tell you which
agencies each one is responsible for
right so this is something I never got
straight last time so uh so this is a
really good list right and so um and
they're authorized if you have any
questions about any agencies or want to
contact somebody in an agency they will
help you out you don't have to go
through me to to get to them right so
they'll they'll help you out as you need
it and with that Melissa is going to get
us going
good afternoon division one and welcome
welcome new members and it's good to see
you guys again happy to be here um I
think representative Maguire took some
of my presentation so that's great less
for me to say less for you to have to
listen to me speak to um most of you
here are familiar with me I have been
with the LBA for three years now I
previously came from Department of
Revenue where I spent most of my Adult
Career there um I landed as a senior
financial analyst my last several years
there I worked mostly with Ways and
Means at that time so I was on the
revenue side of Staff projecting
estimates um and living in that world so
it's been interesting to swing over here
the last three years to see now how the
state spends the money in the budgeting
side of things um as representative
Maguire stated we have Jack Mullen now
who is part of our team you don't see
Mike Hoffman here he did retire however
he will be helping us in February sort
of in the background with any additional
uh workload that we might need so it'll
be good to have him back um Jack I'll
let you introduce yourself and talk
about where you came from so my name is
Jack Mullen I previously worked in the
Senate clerk's office for the past 10
years so I have a little different
perspective of the process so it's going
to be fun to help you guys and learn
with you guys through this budget
process this
year we're very excited to have Jack so
some of this presentation before I start
I did steal from Mike KES just because I
saw thought there was some overlap as
well as him giving 92 pages I didn't
know where this document would end up
for you guys like he said as a coaster
holding the door open extra reading
materials so ours is skimmed down to be
a third of that uh with some additional
information there but some of this might
be a little bit repetitive is just our
office it has the new emails we did hand
out our card because I don't believe
these new emails are effective until
next week and if there's any issues feel
free to use our old emails because I
believe those are going to be active for
a while so they will forward over but I
just wanted to make sure you had both
ways to contact us in case the new one
doesn't work or there's some hiccups
along the
way on the second page as representative
Maguire alluded to you have two of us in
here uh Jack and I do have distinct job
duties within this group uh
Jack is taking over what I pre
previously did which was the General
government in category one which will'll
go over on the next page I have taken
over what Mike Hoffman did which was
Category 2 and three we also have Mickey
landan who does category uh oh excuse me
who does division two which is safety
and education fish and game and then
Kevin does uh Department of Health and
Human Services in division 3 we do have
a lot of agencies which is why you do
have two analysts in here there's a lot
to cover um a lot to get through but
we'll help make sure that we're tackling
all of those agencies and staying on
track for the
timeline so as I alluded to if you turn
the next
page it's just the the division of work
between Jack and I is not just randomly
divided there are different categories
mik Kane spoke about them but I was
going to go over them as well so
division one is General government those
are your bigger agencies like
Services uh Department of State Treasury
oplc and then it switches over to
category two and three which is what I
will be handling which is your category
two is Administrative Justice and public
protection and then category three is
resource protection and development and
you can see the agencies within each of
those different categories it has below
each category how the division is broken
up for within the departments or some of
the administratively attached agencies
to each of the Departments but this is a
good resource guide just to know when we
start talking about categories or what
agencies do I handle that because I
don't see it on the first page of the
big overarching departments but it's a
good reference guide to see what
agencies you are responsible for I do
want to note too that although Jack and
I have distinct agencies we do work well
together if you're like I don't remember
who's handling what but feel free to
email whoever you want throw us both on
the email we'll get the email to the
appropriate person or answer if needed
we'll both be in here quite a bit
together we'll be hearing this
information uh so don't feel like you
can email um Jack or you can't email me
on a certain specific topic we will get
it to each other and we'll make sure
we're providing you the best service
without a delay of who does
what if you turn to the next page so you
probably got the not already next week
we will start be start to hear some
bills I think believe next Thursday full
Finance we'll have four bills I wanted
to bring in a couple of examples for a
fiscal note we made some minor changes
but I also just wanted to talk about
Appropriations versus expenditures there
were some questions that came up over
the last couple of years and maybe some
misinterpretations of how the bills are
written and how that works you may
already know this if you do feel free
not to listen but I did want to just
point it out so we can make sure we're
providing you with the most accurate
information so the the one biggest
change with our fiscal note it doesn't
look exactly like this this is just a
sample but up top you'll see after
fiscal uh impact there is a statement
for this example bill that I threw
together it says this bill does this
bill does provide funding it should have
said not sorry about that of course
first issue I'm sure there'll be a
couple of those uh this bill does not
provide funding nor does it authorize
new
positions so we thought if we called
that out in the beginning there may be
less confusion about does it provide
funding I see a number in the
expenditure line so we're giving the
agency this money or the agency says
they need positions so we're giving
those them those positions just because
an agency States they need x amount of
positions or they State this bill will
cost x amount of does not mean they're
authorized to use that funding or to
hire for those positions so in this
example that I gave you you'll see the
expenditure line says 500,000 for each
for 26 and 27 and in DET terminable for
28 the next line that you really want to
pay attention to is that appropriation
line so the appropriation line in this
bill is zero which means there is no
authorization for that agency to have
that funding that is strictly the cost
of what the agency or the LBA has
determined what the bill will cost for
them to uh
Implement so just something to be aware
of because what that means is if this
bill were to pass the agency is required
to stand up that program however they
may not be able to do it because they
don't have the funding or they don't
have the positions to do it they are not
authorized to spend an additional
$500,000 they won't have that those
dollars in their budget so just an an
important concept because the bulk of
our bills that do come down that we will
see in finance will have an expenditure
line but they will not have an
appropriation for that those
expenditures and that can be okay
sometimes because the legislature this
division could say I think you could
absorb that into your budget or I think
you could shift resources to do it so we
are not going to provide the funding
however on some of these big programs
you may want to make an amendment to add
an approv ration to it or you may want
to hold the bill retain the bill study
the bill or kill the bill because they
won't have the proper funding to stand
up and do what um what is authorized of
them in the bill so I just wanted to
point that out we have little asterisks
down there as well on the fiscal note
now that says expenditure is cost of
Bill appropriation is authorization to
fund cost of
Bill
questions no well let me make clear so
when you say does not provide funding
you mean that the Appropriations line is
zero correct is that right corre because
when I first read it I thought well that
means the revenue line is zero but
that's not true that's not true okay so
the only does not provide funding would
only be in terms of covering
expenditures that's what we mean when it
says does not provide
funding so if you flip to the second
page this is just showing you that exact
same example except you'll notice up top
for fiscal impact it says this bill does
not authorize new positions but it
doesn't say anything about the funding
and that's because if you go down to the
appropriation line you will see that
there is an appropriation or
authorization for the agent agency to
have and spend
$500,000 out of General funds in 26 and
in 27 however the agency still does
state that they need uh I think two
subject matter experts is what I put in
there but they don't have authorization
to fill those positions so just an sort
of a overview and just something to look
at when we're getting these bills and
we're like we can't spend this but are
we actually spending it or is it just an
expent that that the agency
States Representative Ms thanks Mr
chairman so I guess I'm that one
confuses me that they they've so they're
saying that these new positions is going
to are going to cost
$500,000 there's authorization to spend
$500,000 but they can't spend it because
they can't hire the
positions partly correct so it does say
that it's as well as for new office
space equipment as the cost so
essentially they could get the office
space and they could get the equipment
but yes you are correct they have funds
or dollars now for a position but the
position cannot be established because
that has to be authorized by the
legislature in the bill so there if you
wanted to give them that $500,000 and
these bills do come through like this
where they're a little bit deficient in
what is actually needed and it could
have been that the sponsor didn't
realize they needed additional positions
until after the um after the fiscal note
came
out but there could be an amendment if
you felt that $500,000 per year was
appropriate and you wanted to pass this
bill you could do an amendment which
Jack and I could prepare to give
authorization to hire two new positions
so sorry so anytime um any time there's
a new POS a an agency wants to hire a
new
position they they have to get specific
authorization to hire those people it's
not just spend the money they have to be
they have to get authorized to hire the
position that's correct okay thank you
yeah we we control spending in sort of
two ways one is the dollar amount but
also there's an authorized number of
employees and so if that doesn't grow
that tends to keep the dollar amount
lower yes representative evil yeah I
mean just slightly more nuanced
representative Ms is that the budget has
to authorize the creation of a new
position and that position will have you
know a
classification associated with it it's a
fairly detailed thing to create so you
don't just authorize the agency to hire
somebody it's a very specific
statutory
authorization and again if you um needed
an amend for that we would help make
sure that you have all the information
in there that is needed for the position
and the
detail so moving from fiscal notes into
the operating budget process I wasn't
sure Mike Kane was going to go over this
he did go over this so it's a little bit
redundant but I I will just break it
down for division one purposes um as we
get those bills they are going to come
in we will typically retain division one
will retain the Bill if they feel they
might do something with it until we're
getting hb1 and hb2 and then we'll add
it on to hb2 I'm going to go over that
further in the presentation but just as
a high level of where we're at um like
Mike Kane said the agency phase started
a while ago before most of us were even
aware of it that was March through octo
October what's a little bit different
this time around versus um when the
members who this is their second uh
second session doing this was that
the same process occurred two years ago
however it was governor sununu's budget
then and he was the incoming Governor so
he was just sort of sliding that
responsibility over for him to do his
own Governor face budget in November and
February this one's a little bit
different different as we are handing
off to a different Governor so um there
may be I say that because there may be
more significant changes than those of
you who attended the agency phase
presentation
I imagine they're going to look quite
different now as it's being handed off
to um Governor aot to
present so we will get that presentation
maybe somewhere between
um want to
see let's actually we'll Turn the Page
just because we do have dates there um
we will get the
governor's presentation um or she'll
give it probably between the 12th and
the 13th as what we're guessing because
it has to be before that 15th which is
on a Saturday um and then she'll come
and her budget director will come to the
full finance and give the presentation
to the full Finance at that point our
committee work can begin on the budget I
looked back two years ago and it looks
like we did start hearing agencies that
day so we will start uh start our work
on that day at least getting the
agencies come because at that point they
will be able to talk about what is in
their budget we do have agencies
starting to be scheduled on the 22nd I
think we have a pretty full day that's
strictly for them to come over and come
and give an overview of their budget
it's more of like a training for some of
the new members it's uh can help jog our
memory of what they do how they work
what they're responsible for before they
come in for the budget because that can
be a lot to to remember especially with
so many agencies of learning what they
do what they handle and then also
talking about the budget all at the same
time can be a lot so that will be
helpful for us to get sort of our feet
on the ground understand what the
agencies look like but then they'll
they'll start coming in like I said
probably around that week the the week
of February 17th through the 20th we'll
start scheduling in these agencies to
come in and they'll come in and they'll
talk about their budget they'll talk
about what the governor gave them what
reductions they had and then they may
also have additional
requests we have about six weeks to get
through all of these agencies and that
is hb1 and hb2 so as Mike Kane said hb1
is about 800 Pages we have a big chunk
of that to go through that we'll be
looking at budgets class lines um and
figuring out where changes need to be
and then we also have hb2 we don't know
what that's going to look like this year
but that's also another large bill that
we have to get through simultaneously
with hb1 as Mr Kane stated we will be
getting hb2 a little bit sooner
typically before we try to get something
from the governor's office the LBA
office would go through and come up with
something for you guys to see but we NE
we didn't have the language for you so
it will be great to have the language in
front of us it will allow us to get
moving a little bit quicker before we
have the official
document Melissa just shut do you happen
to have a an extra one of these handouts
yep there's a pile right over there does
represent of vol me you need one or
you're all set okay I'm
sorry okay very good
all I'm sorry continue yeah no
problem um so we have about six weeks
the division work needs to be done
probably around March 26th that's going
to be a pretty tight hard deadline for
us to get to and the reason that is a
little bit early is
because representative Maguire will need
to and possibly with representative
crails will need to present to full
Finance what divisions one did and that
will probably be somewhere between March
31st and the 2nd April 2nd because it
needs to be add of full Finance by April
3D so just saying it one more time so
it's all in the Calendars our deadline
is probably about March 26th for
division one
work and at that
point once the uh the house is all set
we stop here we switch gears and we go
over to the Senate and start working
with them so we're not as available
after that that point however we still
be we still will be over here in limited
capacity to hear bills but Senate does
become our priority at that
point and you can turn the page to page
eight which is just Senate deadlines in
case again you needed it and just wanted
a uh small handout versus the big
handout of what Senate looks like and
then when uh Committee of conference
occurs
which most of you well if you of you in
this room who have been in uh this is
your second term in finance did not get
to experience a committee of conference
a couple of years ago so that will be a
new
experience all right we can go to page
nine again I didn't know Mike Kane was
going to cover this page in depth so I
think you have heard most of these I
just wanted to get this out here as a
good definition of what some of the
terms are for the new members of what
they look like when we speak to them but
also again just to have this hand out
with your stuff so when you're getting
the big hb1 which will be a binder um in
hb2 you can reference this if we're
start using words or you look through
that document and you'll start to see
some of the you know accounting unit or
you'll see um Mike Kane's Surplus
statement you can kind of look back at
this and maybe not have to glance
through the 92 pages to find it so
that's in
there so moving on to page
10 I'll just interrupt and say I find
the Surplus statement to be hugely
useful that's something you definitely
want to learn how what's in it and and
how to read it
so I agree with you on that it's one of
the most important documents probably
that our office
creates so moving on to page
10 again for members who have been here
this looks familiar but I really wanted
to walk you through the process so
you're familiar again with what the
documents look like cuz I'm sure your
first session on here was maybe a
whirlwind of a representative Ms this is
going to be brand new to you but this is
what we compile so you're going to get
hb1 again 800 pages will have that tab
for you index for you and you're going
to start going through
and when the agencies come in they're
going to have requests Jack and I's job
is to keep track of all those requests
so we make sure we can add them to a
document so this document is just for
hb1 only and it keeps track of all the
additional not what's in the governor's
budget this is all the additional
requests that are coming from the agency
that the division has to decide on
whether to approve or not approve so
this is the tracking sheet and you'll
become very familiar with this we will
have a new one updated for you every
time there's decisions made every time
there's changes made it's posted online
we post all our documents online
typically before the meeting happens
we'll have it and we'll have copies for
you so this is going to be your document
to keep looking through it's more of a
highlevel document it doesn't break it
out by accounting unit or class code but
it does help keep track of where those
funds are what we're spending what's
approved what we didn't approve and to
get to the point that the whole entire
document is shaded because we have
covered all of the
requests representative M thank you um
so these additional requests are they
additional agency budget requests that
the governor has kind of gone along with
he's willing or she she would be willing
to support or is this the
agency's kind of wish list outside of
the governor's office so a little bit of
a complicated answer right because I
don't exactly know I don't want to speak
for the governor of whether she approved
these items or not these are the items
that did not make it into her budget why
they W won't make it into her budget
would be her choice sometimes it is
merely an oversight that it didn't get
put in there we have approved some of
those items where it should have been in
the budget and to make um make the
budget work properly you need this item
in there because maybe it accompanies
something that's in her hb2 but they
forgot to put the corresponding
expenditure into
hb1 sometimes it may not have been a
prioritization of the governor or a
priority of the governor so she may not
have wanted in there or sometimes it may
be something after the P after the fact
Because by the time the governor's
office is presenting this budget and by
the time it you know comes to us when
she's finalized that she's probably
finalized it well before February 15th
so something may have popped up that
needs to be implemented or put in here
um that the agency comes to us so
there's a variety of reasons I don't
don't know the answer on exactly which
ones come in but they are not in the
governor's budget these are all new
requests and sometimes a request is does
not necessarily mean it spends more
money right sometimes they want to shift
something from one place to another I
have an extra employee here I'd rather
have them here something's like that and
those things go into the budget anyways
right because they affect money exactly
where it's spent and they change House
Bill one so you know instead of spending
in that column you're spending in this
column so some of these requests are
relatively easy to Grant because there
isn't a change in money this we expect
this budget uh bium to be very very
difficult revenues have been declining
Etc and so um we're going to be we're
going to have to be very ruthless with
approving requests for more money or
more Personnel um because any every one
of those we add we got to subtract even
more from somebody else right so uh to
make the budget balance so uh those kind
of requests are going to be very
difficult to to fund but of course
presumably there will be some because
you know that's a really important thing
and this thing over here is not quite so
important and you know that kind of
thing thank you that's a very good point
ref end McGuire thank you for adding
that there are just simply transferring
class lines that need to come through
here because they have to have
authorization in hb1 to move One Fund to
refunds from one class line to another
so from a travel expense into software
purchasing could be one it's a zero net
change but we do still have to put this
in here and sometimes if you look down
to the second approved item um that
one's put in there because there was a
keying error in the hb1 so of course
that would get approved because it needs
to be
fixed so again this is the tracking
sheet change um will live in breathe of
this
document so that's just did you have
what what's the graying out why so the
graying out is when we approve the item
or make a decision so the grade out is
those sections have already been tackled
so that's when I was saying you hope by
the or by the end of the session or by
the end of our due date the whole entire
uh sheet will be great out because we
have taken action on all of it whether
it is to approve it to deny it I see way
or another just a tracking
mechanism so if you turn to page
14 that was hb1 this is HB 2's tracking
sheet so once we receive hb2 Jack and I
are going to comb through that document
learn it we're going to put
together this spreadsheet for you that
says and identifies which sections
belong to division one there's a lot in
there that typically doesn't impact us
that's for other divisions to worry
about not for us to worry about so these
are just the sections that impact
division one we'll put the section
number in there the page number in there
so it's easy to reference what we're
talking about you'll have hb2 in front
of you you can flip back and
forth you will need to make decisions as
a division what you want to do with
every single one of those items that
impact division one whether it's
accepting the item
you can turn the
page whether it's doing an amendment to
change what is an hb2 to reduce an
amount to increase amount whether it's
to delete a section that needs an
amendment whether we hold the item which
means we need to go we being Jack and I
need to go back to the agency and get
some follow-up information before the
committee feels comfortable enough to
make a decision on that
item or or if you keep scrolling through
to page 20 whether it's to add new
sections to hb2 so the pages
before page 20 were just making changes
to the current document page 20 was all
the new sections that we added into hb2
and that reverts back to what we were
previously talking about where will the
division will retain bills and then add
those bills with Appropriations into
hb2 so if you look at the first one for
instance ads content of HB
374 you'll scroll down to you know a
couple down and you'll see ads content
from
hp230 and a bulk of these are just
adding bills that the division has
retained but would like to see go forth
in
hb2 again with hb2 there are amend
amendments needed with anything that we
t change within that unless we approve
it no amendment is needed those
amendments will flow through Jack and I
we work really closely with OS to get
those done and turned around pretty
quickly uh it's much faster if they flow
through us so we do ask that they all
flow through us we can keep track of
them we keep track of the amendment
numbers on this sheet if you go outside
of us it makes it a little bit difficult
to figure out what's going where and we
want to make sure we don't miss anything
so again please float any amendments
through Jack and I
yeah and hp2 is a huge part of the time
we spend on things because our section
is going to be so much larger than the
sections that other agent other
divisions deal with and so we'll tend to
um if we're meeting with an agency for
an hour and it only takes 45 minutes
we'll stick 15 minutes of talking about
the next few sections of hp2 into that
time so that you know we get things done
on on time yes
if you turn to the next page page
21 so we went over we're back on hb1 now
so we went over what the tracking sheets
looked like for TW for hb1 this is the
final change for hb1 what it looks like
for this Division and this is what Jack
and I will compile for you this is
called the detailed change so this tells
you what accounting units were changed
what the impact is and then the comments
of why we changed it so this is
something that representative Maguire
will present to the Full House Finance
this is the document this is what was
used last year when represent or two
years ago when representative leishman
and representative Maguire presented
they will go through all the changes
that have been approved to division one
and you'll see a comment side on the
right so it can help remind you why we
made these changes very useful
document oh representative I did want to
point out because you did have that
question um you had the question about
doit and what that looks like and if you
go
to page
22 at the
top you will see there it says it salary
and
benefits you'll see the statement of
funds is O which is other and then it
has an amount there and then it says two
new technical support
Specialists U for revenue for Dr if you
turn the page to line
49 of the next page you will see that
corresponding line for those positions
that come from the general fund so
that's where that that devil accounting
does happen so you're going to have the
general fund receives the appropriation
or the authorization for that position
but then
um you have to have the corresponding
line because that money does get
transferred to oit but it's an inter
agency transfer it's for the books just
to keep track of what
doit
um how they're allocated their funds for
their
budget and I'm
sorry sorry another question um on page
21 uh I just want to make sure that I I
get the termin ology right so in the
accounting unit
column the what do each of those numbers
represent like 01 is that the what is
that is that the governmental unit or it
is the governmental unit and we have in
our notes from your presentation we're
going to send you um a link to
das's website they have a great manual
that will break down all these and a
definition for every single code that's
helpful for you but it is the overall
government one then it has the agency
codee or the department code then it has
the agency code yeah that's what I
wanted to understand what so the O the O
if we could just 01 is the governmental
unit yep and then the O3 I'm looking at
line 11 03 represents the first 03
represents what the agency agency the
second 03 is Department it's also within
the agency so that number would change
um when we met the other day we talked
about administratively attached agencies
yeah so that number would change if it
was an administratively attached agency
right but because this is um it for
liquor it's the same those two are going
to be the same and then the six digigit
that's that's a combination of the
department and the agency code and the
funding oh okay and then the 7677 that's
the accounting unit okay so that will
drill down to a specific part of the
agency
okay and then it e it does even go
further for us where there is a class
code at the end of that which will be
which will identify the specific expense
okay that it goes with whether it's
office space or co uh Personnel cost or
benefits Etc but we will get you a
document that will help you understand
that a little bit better and if the
whole whole division would like it we
can also email it out it's a pretty big
document but it does have thank you a
lot of items in it so again if you turn
to page
24 you'll
see that this is what was done for
division one the total funds that were
spent um by the funding source and this
is just for division one category one
because we do break it out uh for
category the different categor sorry I'm
trying to avoid the Sun a little bit you
can see
and then the next couple of pages I just
wanted to show you because we do Break
It Out by category we do have category
two this is what we did excluding safety
because we don't have
safety um it has the breakout of those
funds you'll notice when you get to
category two how much smaller the
general funds look like versus what they
look like for category one because as
you get into Category 2 and three you do
start to shift away from General funds
and it's more federal funds or other
funds and then on page 28 that's
division or that's Category
3 and then at the very end on page 29
it's a summary of everything combined
from all the categories of what division
one did for uh whether it's a reduction
or an increase in different fun
sources on page 30 we talked about
hb1 on page 30 the bulk of that is hb2
this is the final presentation again
that will be given by the division chair
to full
Finance it's a summary for them to go
through it will say what we did to hb1
or hb2 there's always typically a couple
of hb1 amendments um that do need to be
put in there whether there is an
abolished position the estimates of
unrestricted Revenue always comes
through division one so that is always
put into the
document and then in this case there was
a new hb1 where they put an
appropriation for a position for
Department of Information Technology
that section is typically pretty
small
hb2 when we went back to the other
document that I was going through this
is the finalized version so this will
have have the list of everything that
was changed deleted or added for hb2 it
goes from page 30 to
31 and within this packet we only put a
couple on here but within the packet
that goes that is presented in front of
full finance will be all of the
Amendments um however many is listed
here you know 20 or so amendments behind
there so people can look at what was
done and talk about what is done and
Jack and I will coate this entire
document to have for full
Finance that's the end of the
presentation I have as the sun is
aggressive do you want to explain page
32 what it
does I know what it does oh sorry I do
that yeah sure but not so page 32 it
looks a little weird you're like what is
any of this mean so we had a um we had
during the budget process
Department of Revenue received a couple
of positions and in order to receive
those we unfunded or um abolished a
couple of positions so this is an
amendment to hb1 if you looked at hb1 it
is just numbers there are not words
besides the footnotes at the end so this
talking representative mums if I can see
you over there um this is the codes that
we talked about so here's the exact
position identified in das's budget
system of what needs to happen so this
abolish abolishes three positions within
the Department of
Revenue so it doesn't look like a lot
but when entered into the budget system
it takes care of what is needed yeah and
you would have to know that section five
is the section that abolishes and
section four is the section that adds or
something like that right because the
the thing that adds positions looks very
similar yes and and the and the numbers
are they the um represent of M oh sorry
sorry sliding
and the numbers are they the um the the
fiscal
year uh numbers the the three numbers
what do they
represent position those are the
position the position numbers yeah so
position numbers every employes job has
a five-digit number and I don't know
that they're in some kind of a system
right I think they're just
numbers yeah I'm not sure how Das
assigns it but we all do have a specific
employee code attached to us right yeah
Melissa's job as a number Jack's job as
a number
Etc so that means we're limited to
100,000 employees right
so all right thank
you any more questions for Melissa or
Jack well you know you're the one that
hasn't been through this before
but take yeah yeah we're good we're here
and happy happy to help with whatever
you need we'll learn along the way we do
not know all the answers but we are good
at getting answers so if there anything
pops up and you're you have a question
for an agency um you're always welcome
to go to the agency yourself but if
you'd like us to just if you want to
throw it at us we'll go through and we
can do that for you um we'll let you
know if it's going to take a while or if
it's a heavy lift and if we can fit it
in as well because obviously there's two
of us who are trying to fit this all in
but for the most part I think the
members would feel we accommodate most
of your needs that are requested yeah
all right so Janet and and Melissa and
Jack and I have started to schedule our
meetings with
agencies um and they're just sort of
overview stuff for for now right they're
not going to be able to tell
us this is what we put in hb2 or this is
what we put in hp1 they'll just be able
to tell us about their agencies and in
general what's going on with their
budget and so those are going to start
next Wednesday and we'll be here pretty
much full days on the following four
Wednesdays I think um and and then we'll
get to February 15th and then we'll be
here most of the days um or you know as
many as as needed so um plan on just
being here all Wednesdays if possible
for the next
months okay would uh representative Wier
or Lehman like to add anything cuz I
don't I don't have anything specific to
to we're just going to keep an eye
on yeah if he pulls out a white board
look you know I found out I I I found
out that was totally against house rules
right so I shouldn't have done that yeah
yeah all that that stuff because we're
not allowed to have the reason we have
so much paper is we're not allowed to
have charts and and displays and you
know all that other stuff right so
um even though I think it would make
sense but it's it is a house rule
against all that kind of stuff
so an admission against interest
yeah anyways
to representative you
yes so yeah that was a good question um
and so what I said was we'll we'll try
to avoid taking votes during that um
that week and but I don't know I hearing
from representative wer I'm
not okay no but the question was about
about vacation week break week yeah
we'll have to look at the progress
right cuz my other committee won't be
meeting that week right so
yeah
e
e e
so it's not that
big e
else want to say something no okay we'll
see you all at 9 o'clock on
Wednesday thank
you definitely nine not
10 e